[Music]
what up guys
welcome back to off the record two
daddies in a baby edition where we talk
about
whatever the hell we want
bringing some life up into this [ __ ]
dude i saw this one video it's [ __ ]
disgusting but hilarious right
so it was the most craziest thing there
was this jungle boy
swimming in a lake he has a cigarette in
his mouth he looks about six years old
or
he looks like a child right he's
swimming and he's keeping the cigarette
dry
yeah that's palliative and in that song
that you know that oh no
oh no no no no no you know that song
that shit's playing in the background
right this was on facebook
and then he he goes like uh like that
and then he comes back and he hits a
cigarette and the lag of dookie floats
up
and he's cracking up right and i'm like
this is what's crazy it's like everybody
has a smartphone now
yeah you could be in the middle of a
like in the jungle and do this that's
great you have a smoking kid
that's taking a dump while he's swimming
it's just and he's making a [ __ ] tick
tock dude
dude yesterday or not yesterday two days
ago i was taking a shower we just
all was in the hot tub and then i went
into the shower
and i was turning on the water to get it
warm because taika is kind of like jio
where he hates
the cold so if he's like if it's cold he
hates it so i'm waiting for the water to
get warm
and i'm looking through the glass and i
see him standing there
and he goes and he just shoots [ __ ] on
the floor
wait wait wait on the shower like wait
outside of the shower he's just waiting
cause he's naked
oh so he just so you know he doesn't
know not to [ __ ] while he's not wearing
a diaper
he knows he's not he's not um he's not
supposed to but he couldn't control it
so you just see him like squeeze and it
just shits on the floor and
he goes because he he's embarrassed he's
embarrassed and he feels bad
but then i was like oh [ __ ] and then i
looked at geo because like my parents
always have the whose turn is it yeah
but then i'm like hey i'm inside
i'm like quarantined yeah
i just don't get like how that's when
you're a kid it's so easy to [ __ ]
standing up
because even like if i wanted to take a
[ __ ] here it would be impossible
or even just start pissing around it's
probably psychological though if i need
a [ __ ] and my
phone died i can hold it until i charge
it enough
and then i could take my phone and
that's like the peaceful [ __ ]
hurts though when you have to really go
and then you're holding it
[ __ ] without a phone so hard
i think i'm programmed now yeah that's
true because sometimes i'll rush and i'm
like i gotta oh wait my phone i gotta
get back and then
uh okay oh yeah it's so weird like
i'm so nice where like i just don't want
to bother anyone so say we're on a road
trip
i'll just hold my piss in right even
though i'm dying
and then i'm like i don't want to say
because then like i grew up where i'm
like
oh can you pull over and they're like no
like just hold it right yeah um
that your parents always like that
everything right you're like dying
uh but now we're adults and then i
remember like i was on the road trip
from
i went to tahoe and then uh we're all in
the car
for like an hour just dying and then my
brother was like uh he wasn't passengers
he told my friend he was like you
couldn't pull over really crazy you
gotta use about them but guys like yeah
and i'm like i could've just said like
an hour ago
like if anyone says no i'm like for a
human body function just like because
you're going to [ __ ] die
that's kind of messed up i think that
when you're a kid though they tell you
no
because they get annoyed at how many
times you got to stop
yeah really dude when you're traveling
in a van full of kids you you're
stopping like every 30 minutes because
everyone's
they gotta go they're on different
cycles too yeah and then they don't
[ __ ] go when you stop
yeah because they get distracted they
start like chasing a dog or something
they get embarrassed and they're like
they can't pee
yeah i remember not being able to pee
after like i needed to and then like
they pull over
but i go on the road i'm like well i
can't act like it didn't have to tell
them like an hour i get that then
did didn't you pee in bottles i used to
pee in bottles
my mom was like nah you're peeing in a
bottle i have uh recently
had like was in traffic and i was like
couldn't pull over
and i was just like let me just put my
[ __ ] uh my hoodie over my dick
and i had an empty bottle and just like
fed it through it wasn't i
didn't feed it through but it's not
small that small uh how to piss
yeah you could squeeze it around i like
had to like put just like the hole
on the lip and like thing and then i'd
like
finish close it put on the side and then
like so just because like
do one bottle if you needed to pee that
bad yeah what was fine
you can stop no i mean i didn't stop if
i need to i would have like
got another bottle of the bottle oh
stopping midstream is like the hardest
thing ever
it hurts when you really gotta go and
you stop midstream
it hurts like the uh the chode area or
the
the taint area yeah that's just
destructive man
what's funny is uh so like um we taught
taika to like
clean his dick with the um tissue paper
after he's done
so that's so now he knows when he has to
pee he first has to
find his step because he can't reach the
toilet so if he has to pee he runs all
over the house looking for a step
oh finally finds his step he puts it why
don't they leave it there yeah
no because he uses it to do other [ __ ]
so it's him like we
leave it at the toilet but he uses it to
[ __ ] climb on the pool table or
whatever
so he takes his step he pulls his
underwear down
and then he pees and then when he's done
he knows how to take the toilet paper
uh dab his dick a little bit and he
throws it and he flushes it
so um the other day i was peeing and he
just
decided to hang out with me yeah so he's
like looking at me
and then i didn't dab my dick so he goes
hey because
you got a your pee-pee and i'm like okay
okay okay i'll do it he goes no
i do so he gets it and he dabs my dick
and then he puts it in the toilet and
then he flushes it out this is so funny
you know kids they take everything
literally
so it's like what he has to do everyone
has to do which is so funny
it's so [ __ ] funny it's and then like
one time i had to yell at him because in
mid
p he wanted to like like stick his hand
in the stream
no no no no no it's so funny i remember
the
when you play like uh swords with your
brothers yeah yeah yeah sword fighting
i i forgot what age you're just like
yeah let's not do that anymore
yeah it was like the funnest thing to do
ever like i remember i had to wait for
him
like because he we had to do it together
oh that's ty
did you have to do like one more for old
time's sake right now
no you should text him hey can we sword
fight one more time up to the barrier
[ __ ] one more time good old time's sake
remember our skit uh piss wars
where we were peeing all over each other
yeah that was crazy
that was crazy i do miss skit sometimes
damn man i do two now i it just sucks
because the last time we were about to
do one
like we needed a covet officer and all
this and it would have cost us like
three thousand dollars just for all of
that yeah that's just
crazy man just to have someone come and
test everything well
we needed two uh like a real location
and a real location requires insurance
and then now because of what's going on
you need a covet officer
and the kovarsker has to come and also
set up like
covet protocol so like everyone that
comes in gets tested here hand
sanitizers i like every station
so like whatever your production is uh
if you're trying to do like a union
production or trying to book an actual
location it shoots up in price
and so for us it was i think our
original budget it would have been cool
with 500 bucks but then also it's like 3
500 and 3 000 is spent on the other
things damn so i'm like oh [ __ ] that's
crazy
you know like now with all the stuff
that you guys
have as parents like the technology and
all the stuff right like can you imagine
being in a cabin with like minimal [ __ ]
and just raising taika
minimal [ __ ] raising taika like no ipad
and stuff yeah like none of the
modern things that we got like think of
just essentials like food
survival [ __ ] i don't know if i could
survive
oh i would love like mini's haberdashery
from uh
hayflate the tarantino oh yeah i would
love to live like that
i think it depends on how busy i am so
if like
no that's your life like you don't need
to do like jk
or whatever like you're like the old
frontier
like you have a cabin i think i can for
sure and then
it's just eugeo and taika and
um you you have all the modern day
knowledge it's just like now
yeah but then you guys chose to be like
homestead
i think i can for sure because i think
for me i
actually just like physical things more
and that's probably why i never really
got into video games because i'm like
why would i play guitar hero if i could
just play real guitar
so i think like for me um i could for
sure do that and that's one of the
reasons why i like even just going
hiking with taika because for that hour
we're not doing anything digital
yeah it's just straight up building [ __ ]
yeah like even if we're just building a
sand castle or something you know
i couldn't play like video games like
all my friends were in like uh super
into like the basketball games and the
football games like dude we could just
go play outside
yeah that's how i would join them when
they actually want to play outside bro
i just didn't play video games in
general i was just in the west video
games though
i i just like there's nothing that
excites me like halo did
oh halo was fun but then like
now that i'm into all these outdoor
sports again
like doing my childhood [ __ ] man it's
like
everything evolved like like
skateboarding everything right so like
going back into it
er it's it's [ __ ] crazier so now it's
like
like all right when you guys were kids
right you would play games for like an
hour or something and it gets boring
right because it's not like games like
today where you can
binge for like 40 to 48 hours because
it's like straight to movies and stories
in the game yeah right before it
was it's easier but now it's like duck
hunt yeah you [ __ ] die you're like
all right let's go outside that's
extreme because people actually went
outside before like people do that
like not saying just because of kobe but
all your friends the only time you hang
out with them is
while playing video games so that is
yeah so you play with them and then
you're like oh this is boring
all right let's go outside and then like
you push each other on a bike or do
something crazy right
and then that life i'm doing now as an
adult
like you're writing you're pushing
darian like we're [ __ ] around like
coming up with new [ __ ]
and then i'm like oh i actually like
that balance
yeah it's perfect for me but then it's
just now without the video games
but like kids now can be stuck on the
computer for like
[ __ ] hours and they don't ever have
to go out and enjoy the balance
i love the balance like even when we
just go camping one of my favorite
things just sitting there doing jack
[ __ ]
you just look at [ __ ] leaves blowing
in the wind or some [ __ ] you know i
always love watching a fire just
how it moves yeah you just watch the
fire you just sit there
and then ty could you try to run into it
that'd be a funny video where you're
just like it's like just you chill
he like gets up and you have him on a
leash and right before he gets you just
pull him back
yeah yank that much when i do um do like
extreme sports though when i come back
home i have trouble sleeping so shout
outs to feels
who sponsored this video because they
sent me some good old cbd oil
and you know it just takes a few drops
to
put under the tongue or like what i like
to do is i'll make some turmeric tea or
something
and then like i would drink that because
if i
don't what ends up happening is like my
heart is like racing still
after i come back from the mountains and
i'm just kind of this
it's difficult to sleep but thanks to
fields now i get to
you know chill out at the end of the day
and i get to change
my feels and transition into a nighttime
kind of routine and it's pretty cool so
what feels is if you guys don't know
it's a premium cbd delivered directly to
your doorstep
and feels offers a free cbd hotline too
to help guide your personal experience
especially if it's your first time and
you want to try it out so they got real
human support
and it works naturally to help you feel
better there's no high
hangover or addiction so join the fields
community get feels delivered to your
door
every month you'll save money on every
order and you can pause or cancel
anytime feels has me feeling my very
best every single day can help you too
become a member today by going to
feels.com
off the record and get 50 off your first
order with free shipping that's f e
a l s dot com off the record to become a
member and get 50
automatically taking off your first
order with free shipping that's
feels.com
off the record off the record
yeah i really enjoy like uh being more
physical and being more in the outdoors
like um and i think that's kind of cool
too like i don't know if taika stumbled
upon video games or anything yet
but like if we go outside right now and
like even if we're just throwing a sock
against the wall or something i think he
just likes being active so i think like
people with a lot of energy
it just helps them out to like exercise
the body and not just like the mind
because i think video games like for
sure you're like
your mind is really stimulated but i
think you also have like a ton of
pent up energy that you need to just
like how do you manage that in a healthy
way so he's gonna get to the age where
all his friends
or he meets friends and they all play
video games i'll play video games so
how do you manage that in a healthy way
going into it like years ahead like you
know
when did you guys become like homebodies
and played games and stayed online
all day like did you ever get to that
phase because i did i was that one so
when i first got the
when halo 3 came out so before that we
always had video games we played a lot
we'll do all these different things but
it was a mac a mix of
going outside and doing those like
everything but then
so especially during say high school
when all my friends
and uh everyone else like this was
junior high high school um they're
playing sports i was
i just alone just video games it was
literally like
lifting than video games oh well at
least you did the lifting part
i completely stopped becoming
active around late junior high and then
from then on i guess the only time i
would go out is like graffiti
and in skating but but still we didn't
do it that much you know
yeah like i used to go out every day in
elementary
school like and play outside and bike
and then like bike
from miles dude and it was it was
different
yeah i don't know i think i don't think
i ever got to that phase because also i
think when i
sit in front of a computer screen too
long i just get a headache
oh so like even you know like i think uh
if i went to play counter strike back in
the day with like you know when you go
on those
uh like pc bundles like those uh
computer rooms
i would play like an hour or two and
then i would just go outside
everyone else was playing like eight
hours yeah it's addicting
like we were doing all-nighters playing
counter-strike
or like before that it was gta or like
just downloading games
and then chatting and then drugs and
jacking off and like
repeat over and over and i remember
staying up for days back in the day
yeah like that's when i got hooked like
as soon as i had
online access i had a computer um i was
just
home all the time i stopped going out
and i stopped sleeping
at night i would wake up
at like i don't know 3 p.m
yeah and then um i would be up
until like 9 00 a.m
yeah so i was on that club boy hour
damn yeah i think for me i always had
something active i think like
before junior high it was like you go to
your friend's house hey is
it so so home and you guys ride bikes or
rollerblade
and then i think in junior high um
my mama dropped me off at school early
because to match her work hours and i
would just shoot
basketball so basketball became like the
hang around thing so i think i always
had that
and then i think uh once i got hella
into drums
it was just drumline so it's almost like
playing a sport so i never really got
into
the phase of just like being inside for
a long time
yeah we had a community pool like in our
apartments yeah so then like
all the time like every single day for
hours like five six hours we'll just be
at the pool oh it's pretty tight yeah
that was fun
and there wasn't like much else besides
like maybe that's why you like hawaii
yeah you love the water i love water too
and then uh
other than that it was like maybe
football here and there but
not much else like not like when our
kids would literally just run around
bike
do whatever yeah i think the tough part
with tyka's generation
is gonna be um i think in my generation
it was kind of like a choice
like do you wanna be online and play
games or play video games or do you
wanna be
going around doing active stuff but it
does seem like
most kids are going doing like video
games or online
so to achieve that balance i think it is
gonna be difficult especially if like
like let's say you got
five homies and they all wanna be online
all day that's gonna be tough
yeah it's fun though man it is fun i
know i don't know
i think that there's a good balance
between the two though because
um you can learn so much like about your
outdoor [ __ ]
like i'm learning about yeah like riding
my motorcycle like my
mountain bike and then technique and
then i take it outdoors and then i'm
practicing that
i do miss being a kid again that i'm
trying to make that
like my adult life like how i missed out
trust me i got to do that 2020 and i'm
[ __ ] i was like dude this is dope
because i was able to achieve
all the childhood kind of things and
then bring it back
and then expand on it and it's almost
like waking up that
eight-year-old in you that's like oh
[ __ ] i've been waiting to do this again
it's fun man what are some of the things
that you feel like you didn't
get enough of when you want to do it um
i think like say group activities
because i did like get injured and like
just fell in love with the gym and it
was fun so that's why powerlifting was
big for me because of the community yeah
uh
but i think finding that something like
that again
um or just being because now like i get
tired quickly outside
like i want to find something like my
own activity that is like my niche that
i really like
um whether even like i was big in like
archery or like random weird [ __ ] that's
tight yeah so it's like
finding that but it's like now being so
close in the city how do i
escape the city even though i love the
city so it's like i have to actually
venture out to do these things
there's an archery spot near you that
does it for free
really yeah they teach classes and [ __ ]
i don't know if they're doing it now
but um devin took me out and
long time ago and yeah they just have a
bunch of
um you just sign up and then i think
it's like
l.a archery or some simple last name
that i shouldn't forget
yeah i just don't get how people get
into those things where it's like
maybe they look at us weird for getting
the power of people i'm like how do
people get into like
paintballs and that's all they do every
day and they get into like these clubs
and stuff
but i'm like you just gotta do it yeah
they probably don't get addicted yeah i
think
i'm uh i'm trying to get to where joe's
at
where i'm just a kid again but because i
have a kid
that's kind of hard but i think i'm like
a year or two away
from doing it because i think once he is
able to
because right now he's just too dumb
yeah so like right now like i can't even
i don't think i could trust him with a
pellet gun yeah but once i can't of
course you can't
like shoot with them in the backyard
yeah or if i can
tag on his fun yeah because cuz i want
to do the same
thing you know like like once he can
like because i saw this video of a dad
snowboarding
uh with a baby or his kid and they were
just kind of carving together
and i'm like oh that's so tight uh but
then i looked it up and it said like
um they don't recommend anyone under
five doing it just because it takes so
much balance i've seen like
i think someone as young as tyka on a
snowboard
i was there crying because i almost
broke my ankle and a little baby i swear
to god she was like this man 360.
she couldn't even think she was just
going down like this and then her dad
was like following her out
yeah i think like maybe i should just
try and take him but i did take him to
um
what was it uh we we went to big bear
and then you know the sleds so i had to
convince him like crazy to get on
because he was
deathly afraid but after the first ride
he was like again
again so i think did you have to have
him on your lap
yeah i put him on my lap um i think he
has to pass that age
because he saw the vlog where he touched
the snow and it was cold on his hand and
just started crying and
just freaked out so he has to get past
that he touched the rock
no the snow he's cause he's like geo
like the part where
geo hates the cold tychos like that too
oh
yeah he he's super sensitive to the cold
yeah he touches the coal and it's like
the worst thing in the world but i think
i'm like a year literally a year away
from
like us doing exactly the same [ __ ]
mountain biking snowboarding all that
stuff so i'm really happy
[Music]
you